avez-vous déjà pris un bain de forêt une
de nos équipes vous en donne aujourd'hui
l'occasion
[Musique]
la nature me fait sentir vivant
la nature me permet de me reconnecter
dans le moment présent
[Musique]
la nature prend soin de nous prenons
soin d'elle à notre tour
[Musique]
ma famille il nous me demande c'est quoi
un bain de forêt genre décris qu'est-ce
qu'on fait en bas de forêt dit
[Musique]
quand j'ai vu la montée de l'intérêt
autour du chinering yuku qui est le bain
de forêt japonais je me suis intéressé
parce que je sais que j'adore les bains
de forêts je suis allé voir la
littérature autour de ça les recherches
autour de ça des recherches
universitaires sont sorties et le
rapport à la forêt qui existait déjà qui
était déjà connu par les communautés
autochtones depuis des millénaires a
juste refait surface
une espèce d'arbre que vous allez
chez Nerim veut dire Foiret yuku ben
dans le sens de immersion
le gouvernement japonais dans les années
70 c'était très préoccupé par la santé
de ses concitoyens il y avait une hausse
des maladies chroniques hausse du tout
suicide et finalement c'est le directeur
du ministère de la forêt de
l'agriculture et des pêches qui un jour
s'est dit mais il faut encourager nos
concitoyens à aller dans nos forêts ça
va leur faire du bien
dans les décennies qui ont suivi il y a
eu beaucoup de recherches scientifiques
le gouvernement japonais a investi dans
ses recherches là et donc chez rémioku
fait partie du vocabulaire des Japonais
maintenant c'est c'est la promenade en
famille dans la forêt mais c'est aussi
une pratique
d'activités de bien-être comme je fais
une séance de sérignacou dure à peu près
trois heures donc c'est un déplacement
lent en forêt parce que quand on le fait
lentement
nos sens sont en éveil
les effets de la nature sur la santé
humaine nous intéresse à titre de
gestionnaire de dizaines de milliers de
territoires carrés de nature
là c'est pas que deux missions c'est de
conserver ces territoires là et de les
rendre accessibles
[Musique]
on a demandé au Docteur Louis berer et à
son équipe de l'Institut de Cardiologie
de Montréal de faire une vaste revue de
littérature pour aller voir un peu
qu'est-ce qui est scientifique et
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire vraiment à ce
sujet-là
il y a des effets bénéfiques qui sont
avérés comme étant très positif pour la
santé globale j'étais quand même assez
pâté de voir la solidité des preuves
scientifiques
l'exposition à la nature permet de
réduire le rythme cardiaque de baisser
la pression artérielle ça permet aussi
d'augmenter l'activité du système
nerveux parasympathique qui permet de
nous réguler nous calmer ça résout aussi
l'activité du scénario sympathique la
capacité qu'on a à rebondir quand on a
besoin de solliciter notre énergie si on
veut et ça baisse aussi le niveau de
cortisol alors ça c'est l'hormone bien
connue l'hormone du stress
[Musique]
il a accepté ça c'est très solide les
gens qui s'exposent à la nature de façon
régulière sont beaucoup moins anxieux
que les gens qui ne pratiquent pas
l'exposition la nature
la conservation du territoire fait déjà
partie de notre mission elle est déjà
justifiée en soi mais ça vient donner
une argument plus pour appuyer sur
l'importance de protéger ces territoires
là afin qu'ils bénéficient aux
générations à venir
[Musique]
l'accessibilité à la nature c'est
tellement important
dans les études la nature c'est pas
seulement les grands espaces et ça peut
être une nature de proximité
l'enjeu c'est vous qui en aide en au
milieu de vie mais qu'on s'assure qu'il
y en a dans les quartiers
particulièrement les quartiers les plus
défavorisés
l'OMS recommande que tout le monde est
accès à peu près à 300 mains de son
milieu de vie d'un espace vert de
qualité et pourtant malheureusement
quand les dernières années au Canada il
y a une réduction des espaces verts en
nous grand centre urbain puis ça je
pense que c'est c'est aller à contresens
complètement de ce que la science nous
dit
prescrit nature c'est un programme de
prescription nationale qui était lancée
au Québec en mai 2022 on invite les
professionnels de la santé à se
familiariser avec les bienfaits de
l'exposition à la nature et d'en parler
avec leur patients pour leur prescrire
du temps nature
par exemple avec ce patient là apprendre
à avoir discuté on t'arriver avec deux
éléments sur lesquels on voulait
travailler ensemble le premier bon on
s'est dit d'aller prendre une marche un
tempo assez léger de 20 minutes au parc
pas loin de ce qui habite trois fois par
semaine puis après bon intégré aussi des
activités de jardinage le 2 fois par
semaine pour 45 minutes ce qui fait à
peu près un total de 2 heures 2h30 dans
la semaine il y a des études qui
démontent que lorsqu'on prescrit quelque
chose qu'on prend le temps de l'écrire
de lessigner de le remettre au patient
les passions plus tendance à l'appliquer
puis à suivre la prescription que un
simple conseil verbal
[Musique]
de Montréal j'adore venir faire des
bains de forêts ici parce que ça a été
une de mes premières forêts urbaines
j'ai quand même travaillé plus qu'une
dizaine d'années ici et
tranquillement je me suis rendu compte
qu'il y avait vraiment une déconnexion
entre les personnes à l'automne et leur
relation à la forêt quand je regarde les
légendes qui sont racontées aux enfants
c'est le petit chaperon rouge en Italie
Gretel s'il y a toujours des monstres
des sorcières ou des loups dans la forêt
et quand je regarde les histoires qu'on
nous racontait à nous enfants chez les
iNous c'est dans la forêt qu'on guérit
c'est là où est-ce qu'il y a la
nourriture tout est possible et j'ai
essayé de le transmettre mieux que je
pouvais avec les visiteurs du jardin de
l'orientation jardin botanique
[Musique]
quand je parle de créer la relation
c'est des fois je vais goûter à une
plante je vais le sentir je vais casser
une branche mais pour toujours me
rappeler que je peux pas juste prendre
il faut aussi que je redonne soit dans
ma relation en étant responsable du
territoire ou juste en remercie en me
rendant compte de ce que j'ai pris on va
donner du tabac parce que c'est un bien
qui était très précieux un moment donné
j'avais pas de tabac puis un énigme
avait dit prends un peu de tes cheveux
puis dépose-les puis juste la sensation
d'avoir attiré un de tes cheveux ça te
connecte ça dit moi j'ai donné quelque
chose parce que quelque chose m'a été
donné
dans la forêt le silence c'est du
savoir-vivre ce qui donne enfin la
parole aux arbres
moi-même je suis pas thérapeute mais en
fait c'est la forêt qui thérapeute alors
dès qu'on va dans la forêt et qu'on
prête attention avec conscience de
toutes belles propositions de la forêt
nous offre on ressent tous ces bienfaits
ce verre on va l'offrir à la forêt qui
nous accueillis et on va lui souhaiter
longue vie
qui soit là encore pour nos petits
enfants et toutes les générations qui
viennent
[Musique]
le savoir qui est transmis c'est de dire
quand tu fais quelque chose tu le fais
en pensant au 7 futurs générations
[Musique]
et c'est pour ça qu'on veut partager les
savoirs Ancestra autochtones parce qu'on
y voit des solutions pour le futur
[Musique]